die auch leute was geht hier ist max und
es kommen mal wieder ein video soll die
seltenheit in den letzten tagen
es nervt mich selbst ein bisschen ich
bin hier gerade falls ihr euch übrigens
fragt in köln in einem hotel übernachte
ich die nächste woche und falls ihr euch
fragt was macht den jugend hier schon
wieder
und wieso macht ja keine anständige
videos für uns als ihr wisst ja hier in
köln allerdings habe auch keinen
richtigen pc und sondern nur mein laptop
tower aber kann ich erkläre ich dass wir
etwas länglichen teil so alles passiert
und warum ich überhaupt erstmal köln
also ich bin in köln ich drehe hier ein
bisschen was das ganze wird sich action
aus nennen da werde ich mit einigen
anderen youtuber die welt einladen und
wir produzieren das so richtig mit
kameramännern so richtig cool und machen
immer so ein bisschen action chat das
ganze wird vorerst auf clipfish
erscheinen links dazu gibt es beizeiten
dann auf jeden fall morgen zum beispiel
gehe ich mit die fashion etwas machte
ich weiß gar nicht was ich alles
verraten dass ein bisschen wissen dieser
so ein bisschen tricky alles ich hoffe
mal dass es einigermaßen aber ich freue
mich auf jeden fall krass drauf
ich werde morgen wie ich mir hier in
köln morgen wenn ich mit peter peters
ein display aufnehmen wo wir zusammen
zocken
ottilien sie ist ein bisschen verdreht
professionalität lässt grüßen
ich werde mit peter lips
wahrscheinlichen let's play aufnehmen
das schneide ich dann eben an meinem
laptop zu ihren e mails aber auf einer
sd karte mit habe immer wieder so etwas
wichtiges mit mikrofon let's play mäßig
und andere gute nachricht ich werde die
drehs alle begleiten aber nicht mit der
eu sondern mit einer lehre ließ zwar
kaputt zu machen aufgesteckt hat ja ich
bin einfach zu gut so gut zu gutgläubig
ich hoffe immer noch dass die
funktioniert aber ich kriege ja von von
ihren tiefen mit dem wir das drehen was
sehr cool ist und so habe ich dann noch
eine möglichkeit als wirklich
aufzunehmen auf jeden fall bluetooth
oder nicht da bin ich auf jeden fall
hallo das hat mir neuen kopf voll cool
grüße an papa danke also keinen spaß
wenn man vor basiert das wahrscheinlich
na ja also das wäre eigentlich bereich
das ist das bad und hier ist das bett
von fernseher und hier bin ich gerade
tut mir leid leute ich habe es irgendwie
ein bisschen verlernt mit der kamera zu
quetschen
das gibt ihr dann auch sehr bald noch
andere dinge ich werde mit luca zusammen
nach wales an
da fand ich sagen aber auf jeden fall
machen wir in road locker an dächern das
will brauche ich auch schon fast auf das
ist glaube ich erst mal das update holt
er internet dürfte glaube ich ganz gut
sein von daher welche das einfach
hochladen jetzt und ich danke euch auf
jeden fall für die getötete die letzten
tage mit mir hatte
es kam ja öfters mal nichts dann kam
irgendwie so ein rennen schied wie das
hier jetzt leider auch wieder
aber ich gebe trotzdem mein bestes das
überhaupt irgendwas kommt lief alles
nicht so optimal
ich hätte eigentlich einfach vor
produzieren soll gibson gästen die ecke
und schäbig und jetzt könnt ihr mich
hassen einstudiert bestimmten hier passt
der txtr hat mir extra blenden
ich habe auch nur zwei stimmen die
partnerbörse ist erklärt so einiges aber
egal
die wird sagen das war's für heute und
tschüss